I almost don't know what I'm gonna say
in this one two Jack and Jill went up
the hill to make a movie or so Jack
and Jill stars Adam Sandler and Adam
Sandler by that he plays a guy a version
of himself and his sister the girl
version of himself which is funny but
not and the girl version of himself is
really loud and obnoxious and now the
girl version of himself is gonna stay
with Adam Sandler for the holidays and
now we have our movie as someone thought
would be an awesome idea now when I saw
the trailer for this movie I was like
that looks like the worst piece of
of the year funny thing it's actually
not it's the worst piece of in at
least two years this movie never had me
laughing ever had one chuckle I was like
in one scene that that's it rest of it
not funny like there's this scene you've
seen it in the trailer they're all
sitting around the table it's
Thanksgiving time there's a lot of
dialogue and it's just not funny like
you ever go to an improv show and it's
just not going so well it's almost
embarrassing you're like I feel really
bad for the people on stage right now
it's just nothing's landing the audience
isn't laughing the more they don't laugh
the less funny it is that was what the
scene was like it just kept going you're
like dude just stop talking the one
relatable character in the movie is
actually at the Thanksgiving scene is
the bum they have this homeless guy
sitting there for Thanksgiving because
they want to be nice and whatnot I had a
point in this really embarrassingly
unfunny scene the homeless dude was like
all right I'm gonna go cuz this is
awkward I was like thank you chairman
for the entire theater you're the guy I
relate to because you said what I want
to say and yuria you're doing what I
want to do 50 bucks it wasn't even the
character I'll bet you that was the
actor the actor was like yeah I'm going
this is embarrassing and they were like
oh that's perfect we're gonna use it
it's no one will know the difference Al
Pacino's in the movie which is kind of a
funny concept I always like it when
actors play themselves in movies like
weird versions of themselves and he does
that in here is he the best part of the
movie yeah he is but then again a five
year old in the movie theater could have
thrown a piece of at my head and it
could have landed not have been like
well that was the best part of sitting
through that movie so it doesn't really
say much but Al Pacino is undeniably the
best part but he's the highest high
followed by the lowest low cuz after
you're like oh that's cool Al Pacino's
in it then you're like oh why is Al
Pacino in here I mean it is Al Pacino
why is he in this movie and then it made
sense I'm gonna give you guys this peace
of mind to make it make sense for you
Al Pacino was the devil in Devils at
the kit and jack-and-jill is hell so the
Devils in hell and it makes sense so now
it makes sense for you you're welcome
but what was Pacino in it maybe sell a
conspiracy from the studios maybe the
like okay we need to make Twilight look
better than it is how do we do that
release the worst movie in the past two
years the week before Twilight that
should make it look better right
probably not and apparently among
Scientology scientifically speaking Tom
Cruise's penis kills your career yeah
Katie Holmes is in here too she's
probably not going to be in much else
the worst part about this movie is you
remember you like Adam Sandler Billy
Madison was stupid funny but still funny
happy gilmore stupid funny but still
funny wedding singer was just playing
awesome what happened to that guy I mean
having really annoying twins in a movie
is just never funny so what are you
waiting right now why am i talking oh
we're not laughing really funny yeah I
love this funny way to see if we go to
sunny sunny not funny here not funny
there this movie's not just this
movie is dog one for each shitty
role Adam Sandler plays in this movie
I've got nothing any I'm sure some
people are going to be like actually
this is not an objective review that's
not your job Jeremy be objective oh I'm
objective this is an objective review
objectively speaking Adam Sandler has a
brain tumor that's an objective fat
because anybody getting sufficient
oxygen to their brain would not have any
part in jack-and-jill objectively
speaking so let's celebrate what Adam
Sandler apparently wants us to celebrate
these days what is your least favorite
Adam Sandler movie comment below let me
know and as always if you like what you
seen here and you want to see more click
right here to say more
you